um a computer
can take input like our brain can but it
has real advantages to being able to
process much more information much more
quickly and much less emotionally so I
am Bridgewater uh created
um like computer chess think about a
computer chess game uh computer decision
making that reflects our thinking and
our criteria and it operates in parallel
like like playing chess with a computer
chess game next to you and we've done
that all through and AI began in 1953
aeon began 1953 in its various uh forms
um and so it evolved there is
um AI is also acquainted with machine
learning okay so now it's important to
distinguish two things
a machine
following patterns and following whether
those patterns will persist in the
future
I think that I want to distinguish
between
um at what I'll call an expert system
what is called an expert system taking
your criteria and putting it in and also
AI which produces a lot of data and
produces then the output of what you
should do
the gap between those two things is
understanding so if uh and I'll just to
hit the Highlight quick
um if the future is different than the
past
and you don't have understanding
AI is dangerous if the few if the future
is similar to the past so you can look
at things if you're doing a surgery you
can have robots do a surgery because
that same cutting is going to happen the
same way you won't have any problems
that's going to be great so the power of
machine learning to make AI is great
okay but when you give up the
understanding and the mute the future is
different from the past it's it's a
different story the markets are
different difficult that way because if
something is learned it's not valuable
because everybody does it so it gets
into the price so it's important to
understand the distinction yes I follow
actively what's going on in all computer
and I think that it's the greatest Force
because what's happened in both of those
ways machine learning and uh also expert
systems is that we have the compute
tutor to give us the capacity to learn
and transact and operate in a much
better way so when you can learn at an
accelerated way because that's what
progress is about productivity comes
about by the fastest amount of progress
because you know how to do things better
and so the capacity with computer-aided
decision making so I'll do throw both of
those in the category of computer-aided
decision making we are making
revolutionary changes in the way that
we're going to do things that are that
man has not seen before and so it's very
very exciting